Well, if you'll permit me to doodle over our grammar,
one way to get started with this is to think about what's in chart[0]
These two are in chart[0]:
(T --> dot p Q r)
and (T --> dot p Q s), and we have seen anything yet.
So if we start from that, in chart[0],
the only operation we can do is to
shift to get to chart position [1].
Shift over the input <p> if that's actually the first character of the input.
Well, it totally is--that's super convenient.
So we're going to move these dots over here and get:
(T --> p dot Q r) and (T --> p dot Q s)
from zero, in chart state[1].
Oh--so both of the first two are correct.
Now we're going to have dots in front of the (Q).
So we're going to bring in (Q --> dot q)
from 1, in chart position 1.
Now we're going to look at the input again
and see that the next token is actually (q).
So we're going to shift over this
and put the result in chart[2].
So in fact, this one's correct as well--wow, we're on a roll!
Now the last 2 involve doing reductions.
We see: (Q --> q) and we've seen all the input we need
by the time we're in chart state [2].
Zero, 1, 2. We've seen 2 characters for the input.
So we're going to go back
to states that had a dot in front of a big (Q)
and say: we have found your big (Q) and we're done with it.
So chart[1] had a dot in front of a big (Q).
We'll conceptually shift over it
and chart[2] will now have the dot after the big (Q).
And another way to interpret this is:
after seeing 2 characters in the input, we could be here.
Well the first character is (p)--great.
And the second character is little (q),
which we reduce up to big (Q) so, yeah--
this is totally where we are; my finger is right there,
starting from zero, with no more hidden tokens on the left.
So, in fact, both of these are also right.
We will do the reduction
and do this sort of pretend shifting,
for this first rule,
and also for the second rule.
In general, we do all the shifting,
all the reductions, all the closures possible.
Boy, it's a good thing we're going to have a computer program do this for us
because doing it, by hand, is starting to get long.
This was a particularly tricky quiz,
so don't feel bad if you missed a few of these.
In the end, though, all of them were right.